we had begun the process chris of
spitballing yeah potential head coaching
candidates in washington for 2020. it's
bill callahan for now unless he takes
that team to the playoffs he's not going
to be the coach next year right so so
who do we think it'll be yeah we talked
about urban meyer right reunited with
dwayne haskins right i like that idea
yeah i get it but
what what other names come to mind for
you yeah okay um i think the ones i look
at it eric b enemy all right for for the
kansas city chiefs the offensive
coordinator i think he's head coaching
material here's what's amazing yeah last
year all those jobs were open it's
ridiculous never got a serious sniff i
think that was ridiculous okay uh for a
lot of reasons but i'm gonna go there
right now okay i know you you brought up
mike mccarthy a few minutes ago i think
that could be a real possibility
right packers coach right motivated
available right and guys like him and
urban meyer are the kind of guys oh we
need to get the organization
straightened out and get things going in
the right way and all have a common goal
and get it all going there you know the
i look at like a michael mccarthy he is
certainly capable of doing that and then
the other one that really jumps out to
me because i think the guy is one of the
best coaches in the sport and i know i'm
biased here but it's josh mcdaniels i
look at josh and just i you know i had
time with him as a player and working
for him in new england and i just think
the world of him because i've seen his
detailed daily approach and what he's
all about and uh he would be one name i
would certainly think about as well
would he ever i don't know i don't know
he was just there yesterday i know he
walked into that third world country
masquerading as a football stadium right
right he's smart enough to know that
it's dysfunction from top to bottom
right i just don't know that for a guy
who's got options now it was weird
because last year
there wasn't as much interest in him
people were recoiling a bit from what
happened with the cults
but i just don't know that he could give
up new england maybe not for an
organization that that really needs
ultimately a gutting yeah and bruce
allen i'm sorry
bruce allen needs to go if jay gruden
needs to go bruce allen needs to go
and some would say dan snyder needs to
go but you can't fire the owners
said a few years ago and the 49ers were
much worse than they are now other names
that we have bandied about jim harbaugh
right not as sexy as it would have been
a couple of years ago no yes but how
about jim and john harbaugh right down
the road from each other in washington
and baltimore it's a nice family story
but that's a disaster for the redskins i
mean the jim harbaugh love affair is
over i mean it's it's i just he's
overrated and you know i don't like him
and i got nothing good to say about him
but what happened in michigan i mean how
is it he was he's supposed to be an
offensive coach and his offense stinks
okay every problem well he changes
offensive coordinators every year and
it's still the same crap so oh something
tells me he's micromanaging and it's his
offense even though he likes to blame
offense coordinators and then i mean you
see michigan in enough college football
i mean yeah they got some good defensive
players they got no game breakers on the
offensive side i'm i would bet you a lot
of kids meet jim harbaugh and they're
like i'm not going to play for that guy
let me go somewhere else he does have a
vibe about him it's a jerk that's the
vibe you're a jerk jim there's a vibe
there's a vibe that you know you can get
away with it when you're winning like
bill belichick right belichick's a jerk
you can get away with it when you've got
pelts on the wall or pellet jim does
bill doesn't treat human beings like
jerks off the field though and jim does
jim's a jerk all around i have nothing
positive to say except that he's a jerk
sorry that's not positive no i i know
you're right well it's positive i can go
worse
the jerk is the positive positive about
that really want me to go let's get a uh
explicit version of pfdot how about this
how about this right because dan snyder
got joe gibbs hall of famer at the time
joe gibbs out of an extended retirement
does he make a similar
let me dust off a legendary coach like a
bill cower yeah does he call tony dungy
tony would hang up the phone immediately
i assume but is there an older coach out
there who's out of the game right been
out of the game
but maybe could be brought back to the
game and could it be cower after all
these years could dan snyder dangle
enough money to get bill cower cower
cower's the only one that i like
i can think of that fits that narrative
at least right now off the top of my
head i haven't put a whole lot of
thought into this whole thing yet
it's been a long long time there's not
even any talk about him coming back no
more gruden it continued you're right
power it ended five years no it seems
like he's even given up trying to get
his name in the conversation he's
perfectly happy with his his next phase
of life or where he's at right now but
jeff fisher's available yeah i mean
listen i would think about jeff fisher
the gm i would say that jeff fisher has
got an eye for talent if you want
somebody to go in there and maybe get
the organization headed in the right way
that way i think that would make a lot
of sense i don't know if you're gonna be
able to sell to your fan base he's the
right head coach if mike tomlin gets run
out of pittsburgh oh
that's a good one i could see mike
mccarthy in pittsburgh and maybe tomlin
in washington that's that's he's a big
eastern virginia guy that's close enough
that makes a lot of sense i mean mike
tomlin has the energy and uh you know a
charisma and personality about him that
i do think he can kind of change the
aura of a franchise around in a hurry
jason garrett if the cowboys don't keep
him although i can't imagine washington
wanting jason garrett yeah we mentioned
josh mcdaniels mike pettin mike pettin
is i mean he deserves to be in these
kind of conversations i think probably
when the i mean gosh you you look back
at what he did with the browns you start
to go uh that was a pretty good job for
that crap team at that point in time uh
you know we've got to continue to see
what he does this year but i do think
mike pettin is worthy of being a head
coach again in the nfl let me give you a
name that kind of fits into the idea of
an older coach
but that wouldn't be a guy who comes in
and says i want bruce allen out of here
i'll just kind of go along with whatever
ownership wants okay are you ready yeah
wade phillips oh
yeah i i okay wait yeah here's the thing
we are taking
what an abnormal team would do that's
why it's like no all due respect to wade
phillips but you know wade phillips is
in that north turner category where
they're good enough for coordinators to
periodically fool someone into thinking
they can get it done as head coaches
right but we're trying to project what a
dysfunctional organization is going
gonna do and that would be a way to kind
of
bring in an established guy definitely
who would work he would just keep got
some energy personality yeah knows how
to coach the players up knows how to
approach defense you're right i mean
there's some positives there about wade
phillips i mean hey i mean we all agree
i mean he got a little bit of a raw deal
certainly with the dallas cowboys i
don't think there's any denying that and
he is one of the better defensive minds
we've seen in football over the last
past two weeks well yeah they've had
some issues there there's no doubt um
but but i get what you're saying there i
think really i just i'm just sitting
here and i'm going to continue to
spitball this but no way greg williams
stats is suggesting greg williams he was
there at one point yes
um under joe gibbs yeah
and uh you know yeah yeah i don't think
so that's that's going to be hard
you know i think but again it's trying
to predict what a dysfunctional team is
going to do right it's got to be there i
think like you're like a mccarthy
a tomlin if that happens in urban meyer
or
somebody young and exciting that the
family riley yeah lincoln riley i want
to say yes to that type of guy but i
also want to go like
you know cliff kingsbury's offenses
nothing special at this point you know i
think we need to just calm down with
that a little bit you know does somebody
emerge from sean mcvay staff from kyle
shanahan staff uh one of those guys
because of course they were all in
washington together mcveigh was under
shanahan at one point is there somebody
there that kind of rises to the top as
the season goes i don't know uh but i
think we've hit a lot of the the main
names i would come up with i wanted to
have as comprehensive a list as possible
because inevitably it'll be someone we
didn't mention it could most likely uh
we hit some good ones
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports